episode is brought to you by t-mobile
the US brought to you by t-mobile
the uncarrier oh my goodness John I
don't know why you didn't do that
announcement just now live since you're
here I was I'm just that good um I have
one announcement I just want to take a
moment to thank our screen junkies Plus
members because of them were able to do
this amazing thing so if any of you are
screen junkies plus members in the
audience thank you if you're not what
the hell are you waiting for and if you
want to enjoy nearly twenty three twenty
weekly original shows and hours of live
content join right now at screen junkies
plus straight sorry
screen junkies comm slash plus and if
you use offer code SJ Central sixteen
you will get 50% off the annual
membership it's the best deal we offer
all year that's crazy man cannot believe
it so you guys we are here screen
junkies central the very first year we
are doing this you guys are vanguards
you guys are vanguards I want to ask
Andy right off the bat when you
conceived and created honest trailers
years ago you knew this exact thing was
gonna happen right impossible it's like
we I remember even when Dan joined and
we went to comic-con we always have the
hotel that's like 30 miles away we were
lucky to get maybe one celebrity to talk
to us the fact that now we have these
fans and this amazing event and this
it's it's unbelievable
yeah beyond words and so grateful
because we're doing this for them like
we have so much fun stuff
over these next three days with all
these people hosting some amazing panels
I can't wait
yeah I mean I think the biggest sign of
our success you mentioned it we used to
be like in the next County now we're a
couple blocks away I got a hotel right
next door how's Rosie that's amazing
Dan how do you feel about being here
being stopped and recognized by people
dan you are a comic-con celebrity it
used to be that people recognize you and
you because you're such a nice guy you
would say like this is Dan he had it's
on the honest trailers there who would
go on the street because they were the
only person that recognized by the way
that person I hugged is now my wife I'm
kidding we obviously shared a breakfast
at the hotel
yeah right and John Bailey you spend
comic-con weekend going up and
whispering in people's ears I'm John and
shoot the epic voice shoot was one of
the worst shoots Oh mad at each other
and tired thing wasn't working they get
beating me lines that were like a
hundred minutes long people running by
now Joe is it have you been to comic-con
before I've been to comic-con before but
uh I think we're off and I heard the new
kids at screen junkie so this is huge
this is awesome so sad yeah Roth tell us
about your past comic-con experience and
what you're looking forward to
fifteen different strangers that you met
on Twitter
ten million miles away and waiting in
line for Holly H or overnight for things
to doing live streams and interviews but
now I'm so excited about this this is
amazing and it's gonna be awesome
but I will say one thing that I'm
secretly hoping happens during the con
is that Kurt Russell shows up for
Guardians because if that man shows up
for guardians I'm gonna kidnap him and
then we can enjoy that and then C Roth
get led away in handcuffs as long as
we're streaming yeah as long as we got
that live Alicia how many Comic Cons
have you been to this is my sixth Wow
yeah so I've been covering it for so
long and I think a lot of people might
be shocked at that because they know me
as more as the indie indie kind of
person but I love Comic Con I love being
in San Diego during Comic Con because
there's so much energy from everyone all
the fans are so excited I love seeing
the cosplay I don't understand any of
the characters but I like it and when
you say you don't understand the
characters you don't understand people
who want to dress up in this man I said
I said my references but they look cool
I shouldn't do it gotcha so let's talk
about this year's Comic Con 2016 what
are some of the things we're looking
forward to there are a lot of panels
there are a lot of things that are in
the offing let's talk with talk about
some of the biggies we got Marvel and DC
Warner Brothers MCU they're gonna have
some big panels are we expecting any big
news from either of them I think they'll
bring out the Justice League that's my
bet they'll bring them out and then
though like have them on stage together
for the first time that's my guess
I think every year Marvel and DC talk a
big talk about maybe breaking up with
comic-con this year every year seems to
be the year where they're like we're
kind of ending this relationship and
then they keep bringing big stuff in so
I'm excited to see what they do yeah
maybe we'll get some thinking new Doctor
Strange maybe some new Wonder Woman
footage
well guardians James Gunn's admitted it
I'm really excited I hope they'd sneak
some footage which it sounds like he's
gonna do they all move to Alaska that's
a bit of a long shot a bit of a long
shot damn to take chances that's what I
love about you oh wait you live life on
the edge of the very edge by the seat of
your pants
uh-oh one of my favorite movies of all
time I remember when I was a kid one of
the seminal action films action sci-fi
films of my youth aliens aliens is
having yeah right
you got Ripley you got the Xenomorphs
a great film oh one of the great quotes
game over man I love aliens 30th
anniversary how do we feel about that it
makes me feel really old but see all the
cost back together again it's one of the
movies that I really love it's such a
great mix like you're saying of genres
yeah I'm gonna get to that word lab I'm
gonna get to hang with the cast and mr.
Cameron so I'll try and kidnap them yeah
bring them over to
but yeah okay I would never kill you
Alicia Kurt or Cameron James Cameron no
Kurt Russell or James Cameron which one
would you keep making shoes yeah they're
both there who do you crush I would say
get away from her you
oh great quote great quote well you guys
that the alien 30th anniversary all of
the panels our friend Kevin Smith is
going to be doing some exciting things
yeah it's gonna be here non-stop yeah
he's gonna be here we're gonna be doing
stuff all throughout comic-con so please
tune in non-stop you're gonna be hearing
from these guys all the time and I want
to thank you for watching and we are
we've got some more stuff coming up and
yeah thank you for tuning in we're still
going oh god chasing the next part now
yeah you know what I just wanted to
start drinking early party start but
before that we have some very special
guests it's a Disney the the beetle and
all that created the some of the
greatest animated films of our lives
they have a new one coming out Moana and
we are lucky enough to have the writers
directors of the film and and B'Elanna
herself
Milana herself so without further ado
change let's bring them out yeah all
right live TV first
all right here we go how I'm excited
because this movie has to rock in it yes
yeah and maybe look so beautiful I don't
know if anything you have the tabs a
chance to see the trailer but the
animation is gorgeous and I'm really
excited about the character of Moana
yeah she just looks like a really cool
female character which Disney's doing a
lot of lately which is great and I can't
wait to hear the stories of how she got
cast cuz I know they were looking for
the voice for a long time they
auditioned hundreds of people hi guys
how are you take a seat thank you so
we're really excited to have you guys
here I mean these two if you don't know
our animation royalty I grew up loving
Little Mermaid as you can tell and
Aladdin and many of the others that
you've done before and Hercules but can
you talk about Moana and where this
story came from so it seems like it's a
slightly different thing for Disney to
do yeah he actually came from John
Wesker over here um about five years ago
when we finished the princess in the
frog we're looking for a new movie to
develop and we were firstly for an arena
where could we set a story that we
hadn't done before and I was intrigued
by the South Pacific of course it sounds
like you are from the South Pacific yes
I sense that somehow so so we get and
but I had never been to like Tahiti and
tsommo and Fiji but I was intrigued by a
books I'd read that were set there and
Payne's had seen the of that place scene
from a Western perspective anyway I I
started reading Polynesian mythology
which I hadn't known at all and there's
this great mythic character called Maui
whom the island is named after
he was sort of a superhero of pollen
he's a great cultural full Carroll
pan-pacific he's known throughout the
Pacific he could pull up islands with
his magical fish hook he was a
shapeshifter
he was a trickster and it just seemed
like what a great character animation
John sounds like John tonight so we we
start developing a storyline I
introduced Ron to some of this
literature and we read it and then
developed a storyline that we pitch to
our boss John Lasseter and he loved the
idea of it but he said you've got to dig
deeper do research so we were forced
first I tell you to go to Tahiti we had
to take one for the team seems like
that's a requirement for Pixar right
it's out of John's obsession they any
movie that John is involved when they
did brave they went to Scotland when
they did wreck-it ralph they went to an
arcade we went to New Orleans three
times big trip we didn't get to write in
a float in the Mardi Gras several trips
to the South Pacific with the project
how did you come to be the voice of I
guess a Disney Princess um it's amazing
being the voice of such an amazing
heroine yeah I initially did an audition
for the part if you watched my audition
and that was actually something that I
wasn't expecting I wasn't expecting to
audition for her but there was something
my friends and I put together
I auditioned for something else
something totally separate and the woman
who is going through those auditions was
also the casting director for Disney on
Oahu so I was able to try out for mana
and the rest is history but I love
there's a video that's online that well
the moment when you found out you're
very mean and we we did a call back he
was actually ye and we we were skyping
with her and we said well you just
wanted to have you tried a few things
could you improv a few things and act
like you're really happy and
got to act like you're happier and he
said well I pretend this if we told you
you got the part
and try and channel that a little bit
and she was so convincing we gave her
the part no actually she was we knew
going in that she had the part she sang
beautifully her personality she's our
character was fearless and headstrong
and smart and alia is all those things
and she has tremendous appeal that and
and sings beautifully she does sing in
the movie and we could have her sing for
you now but we want the rock he was
really excited about Chen Lin Manuel and
Duane was like I can't wait to sing this
song he tweeted all about it and he did
great he I think people will be very
impressed as did Ali a wonderful singer
she she has actually several songs she
sings several times in the movie and
Wayne has a big number if you don't like
my voice I'm really sorry you guys.i
I have to control myself to not fan out
because you are animation royalty and
you just so many films that I love but
John you would mention how strong this
character is and some of the cool
qualities I feel like female characters
and animation are really evolving and
becoming so much stronger could you
speak to that I mean they are and and we
you know we did the Little Mermaid we
did a lab we did Jasmine each of our
heroines at the time we were making it I
think we were trying to take a Disney
heroines to a new place even with Ariel
we felt like she kind of you know pushed
back against her father in a way that I
don't think Cinderella necessarily would
have and but certainly with mallanna I
think we really this is a coming-of-age
story for her
it's a hero's journey it's an adventure
story she is can I say this word on this
in this room badass I'm sorry okay
she is that
and she and she is take-charge heroine
and really I think she does literally
take Disney heroines to a place that no
other heroine has and Ali's been a big
part of that there's a lot of adventure
in this movie there are a lot of
monsters and she faces them with with
great fearlessness and and and just a
lot of the qualities that elite has yeah
there's an aspect of this movie that's a
bit True Grit like in that the rock is
kind of a reluctant participant in the
quest that Moana / Ally he is on so
Moana really has to be strong to get him
to cooperate he's kind of a he has to be
dragged into this someone so it's really
fun they're dynamic between the two of
them is really the heart of the movie
she's recorded many times on different
coasts and the rock but we're going to
get them together I think actually I
think it's in like two weeks or three
weeks I have a date you didn't hear
mom's the word don't tell her what kind
of qualities does he bring to Maui not
just his size but because his voice is
so distinctive well he was really very
interested in being in this movie
because he his roots are so and he he
comes from that area and he really
wanted to do something to kind of
recognize that and he is certainly
bigger than life and in terms of playing
this demigod who has all these
superpowers as a magical fish hook we
can pull up islands with he really
embodies that and then it's been great
was actually Dwayne's great with improv
you know we write the script is written
but we encourage our actors including
Ally to kind of play with the script as
they're recording and he did that and he
did a great job and a lot of his great
kind of comic little asides and ad-libs
are in the movie when your friends found
out about this like what's the reaction
like in school you are the star of a
Disney movie talk about that okay so I
didn't exactly get to break the news to
my friends before they saw it on TV in
the news because they all believed me
when I came back to so saying hey I'm
Alanna and everyone's been really
supportive it's been a lot of fun
recording and yeah I have the best
friends in the world
and how is this whole ride thing
comecon's it's your first time here it
is I've been to one in Honolulu but this
one is one in Honolulu is kind of like a
postage stamp I think next is sorry
sorry but I'm used to you know walking
the floor kind of waiting in line
sitting down and it's different and John
and Rodney have you been to a lot of
Comic Cons we have this we'd have we are
certified Comic Con nerds or we'll join
your club how have you seen comic-con
evolve and change over the years well I
think the first comic-con I was at was
maybe the late seventies like
we shall door hello this hotel and
nothing but comic books and and pretty
much just geeky guys like us that was
kind of the the audience it has changed
obviously hugely in that time I think
that was here the year that Star Wars
you know as I think seventy-seven
Charles Lippincott the guy was promoted
came and spoke a little bit and I do
remember a guy in the audience you know
we used to always talk about this later
because yeah he said how dare you
compare a per sec when it's a unit of
speed and out of time or something it
was the sort of quintessential fan
comment and I was like I was there for
that I am such a fan of all your work
but particularly obviously Aladdin
Little Mermaid and Hercules but you guys
started with the 2d sort of hand-drawn
animation which an experiment at Summit
Red Planet
right and now you're full-on into the
computer I'm just curious like where how
do you feel now with the quit the
comparison well this movie you try and
even again with producing the fragra
film this movie really lends itself to
digital animation the ocean the Pacific
Ocean is a character in the movie and
and bringing that to life and with the
textures and the colors and really
trying to create the beauty of the South
Pacific I think and the textures and the
colors it really lends itself there is
we do have a sort of not too hand-drawn
animation yes Eric Goldberg who animated
the genie the great animator a genius
Eric Goldberg he's animating in our
movie hand-drawn animation character of
Maui is covered in tattoos but this
being animation we thought what if the
tattoos move and come to life so Eric is
anime particular is Minnie Mouse kind of
an alter-ego that the rock has on his
chest who he has arguments with and
talks with and kibbutz's with and
ketches with and and so eric is doing
that animation it's totally being mapped
not just on the skin but under his skin
so it really looks like a tattoo that's
subsurface and it looks amazing what
they've been doing but Eric and so a lot
of our CG animators are working with
their because they do the CG body that
Eric's animation is mapped on so he's an
idol to a lot of those guys so they I
get to work
there at Goldberg it's like you know
working with Olivier or Robert De Niro
or something oh that's great yeah we
made a joke and then on his trailer
particularly put that as we thought wow
that guy must have had the worst job
ahead of me Robin Williams because he's
so there's so much movement yes Eric
Goldberg did Robin Williams and he was
it was an inspiration to all of us what
Robin did you've given us so many
memories and I can't wait to have new
memories created by Moana thank you so
much for now we will be back again I
can't wait great I'll stepping out Rasta
we introduced Roth will I step away by
everybody I'll be back please welcome
back to the stage Roth Cornett
so we're really excited because we have
the conscious one of these
scariest-looking movies this year called
lights out I don't know if you guys have
seen the trailer but the trailer alone
terrifies me we're all set see in the
film you're still alive you survived
yeah it's it's a scary film tell us
about the basic premise of the movie and
when you turn the lights out and see her
but when they turn the back on she
disappears and so it becomes a trick
imagination although that's cleared up
pretty quickly okay please welcome from
lights out
Gabriel Bateman
now we'll have to share them likes a
little bit in this live situation and
just watch well at my exit probably gets
stronger while talking to Teresa I'll
just be like I think the entity when
it's in the dark which of them we don't
really see it is very similar to what it
is in the short film it's it's a
silhouette it's there as Alicia our
actors who play Diana brought this
character to life it got a little bit
creepier and crawly err and in physical
let it move because we just saw this
still shot the shadow in the short film
and that's how it grew it became more of
a character than just like a thing she
embodied it she embodied this whole
thing which makes it a lot scarier than
and we and we do think it's an iconic
character that people will be dressed
here next year just a very scary
creature and in real life she's like the
sweetest supermodel ever great names
yeah yeah great great name speaking of
Alicia because this is played by an
actress and not like you're saying a CGI
character does that make it easier as
actors to be able to get into that mode
of being terrified was she's scary yeah
it is easier to actually have something
physical in front of you to look at
rather than
a piece of tape thing you're supposed to
be terrified so it will it did help a
lot because she would do all the moons
and scratching on the floor and really
for your character very it's playing
with this fear of madness and loss of
control and it becomes almost like a
metaphor right like this darkness and
turn your life and taking it over
it was harrowing to watch what was it
like for you to betray that madness you
know it was it was pretty incredible I
am fortunate enough to have the gift of
bipolar disease and so for the first
time I was able to give an honest
portrayal in a movie about what that
looks like and what that is and how that
shadow self in the darkness can can take
over so I feel like it was a real gift I
got to play that well I've heard you
describe this as you know if you took
away the horror this would actually be a
family drama yeah can you tell me as an
actress to be able to play that is that
it's kind of a gift or something really
unique about this film that you don't
often get the chance yeah for sure I
think most of our lives are like this
and little bumps and it's fun especially
watching a horror movie people's
adrenaline just shoots through the roof
right I think that's why so many people
love this genre that you get to feel
things through these characters and
through this entity that you wouldn't
really feel in real life a great shared
experience to see it in a theater as
well yeah a lot of laughs too in this
film it's good he's the funny guy in
this bill is it coming really we did we
need him you get to relax for a second
and which is the best part about this
you get a laugh and you sit back and you
see and then we come
and just scared the bejesus out of you
which is the best part about it you know
it's not just all scares all the time
you you chill you laugh and then there's
a lot of like let you know people get
scared they giggle a little bit you know
there are those scenes where people are
lurking down the hallway never in the
theaters like hello sorry about that I
was saying amazing things you should
trust that yeah so one of the things
that I thought was really cool was that
there was this visceral raw violence to
her that you don't really see a lot in
ghost stories I think that that really
sets this a bit apart I wondered what
the choreography was like with some of
the sequences with Diana and yeah I
never did a lot of tests with her and
just really worked on her physicality
and they wanted her to be fast really
really fast and she is I mean in the
blink of the eye she's right next to you
and I found that so terrifying because
even when you're acting there were
scenes they wouldn't tell you when she
was going to touch you or grab you you
would just be facing away from her and
you know at some point she's gonna get
you and it is this horrifying I mean
literally I'm like is it now is it now
oh my god and she was just a fantastic
performer Alicia the girl who played her
and she was a she's trained as a stunt
woman now she's just doing a little bit
of acting but she was also a
professional ballet dancer and she just
has this amazing ability to contort her
body in a frightening way that I don't
think we've seen him film before and
you've worked with her before as well
yeah she's my stunt double and I am
Number Four
we'd like go to the gym together
my workout routine and now you're like
get away yeah now I'm like we want to be
going to the gym together actually
anymore I have a question for Gabriel Oh
Gabriel how old are you 11 so as you
were making this movie did you ever like
go home and say mom it's too scary I
want to quit this job
that's if I was 10 or 11 years old
making a movie like this I'm out I
couldn't take it no I didn't while I was
filling but afterwards I could see Dan a
little every time I turned off late so
they go wait so Gabriel you're basically
saying this job's scarred you for life
more like describe me for a week Wow
you're strong-willed I have to say that
Gabriel is probably the most mature of
all of us especially Alexander
definitely and definitely for the most
scares Paul scaredy-cat over here he is
the only one of us who's really
terrified of the dark he's still like I
sleep with the lights on well tell me
cuz I heard a story that something kind
of spooky happened to the house that
you're filming in after your shooting
can you tell me about that you guys
hopefully you'll see the movie and
there's this amazing sequence in the
basement as Tesla said a few times the
basements kind of a character in itself
in the film and a lot of terrifying
stuff goes on in the basement there's
these really creepy mannequins there's
just a lot of it was it was it was a
part of the film that I wasn't part of
so when I thought when I first saw the
movie I was terrified of the basement
scenes and about a week and a half or
two weeks after we finished filming a
friend of mine called me and he was like
hey I think that that house you shot and
is on the news right now and I turned
the news on and it was that I can add
alarm fire and the basement had gone up
in flames and smoke was just billowing
out of this house and so we we haunted
the house the production left but Diana
stayed yeah sorry
you guys do I feel like every single
person either has a ghost encounter or
knows someone that didn't terrify me I
don't know if I can really but here we
go there was a girl who came over to my
house I used to have these little mum
dates with you know the mums and the
babies and she was like oh just so you
know someone was watching us today and I
was like oh it's just like oh it's just
this male entity but don't worry he's
not in the whole house he's just in your
bedroom I was like oh well thank you so
much for that I'm just gonna ignore that
piece of information and then someone
else mentioned that they felt that there
was an energy in my house so then one
night I was telling my husband who is
the biggest skeptic ever I swear to god
I like feel something now maybe he's
watching us and then my husband's like
there's no such thing as ghosts
literally the horror movie moment and 30
seconds later we hit a scraping sound
and we look up we're just staring
through the dark like at our bedroom and
we have this huge big mirror on the wall
and it starts sliding slowly down the
wall just like and then all the sudden
it smashes on the ground into thousands
of pieces and I was sorry angry at my
husband I was like you made the guards
angry I live in next day my very
skeptical husband had a box full of sage
and he's exciting every experience and
Theresa started making the ghost coffee
in the morning just to be frightened now
my body we yeah I do shoutouts to him in
the morning like what's up how was your
night like everything's cool here
however everything's all good wherever
you are yeah
he has great Instagram pics yeah the
girls come back since then I hear noises
but I just ignore them or I'm like hey
what's up how's it going today you know
it's it's fine like I'm just trying to
ignore whatever I hear in the house I
just like to pretend that everything's
okay yeah I've been waiting my whole
life to see it goes even when I was a
little kid I would wake myself up in the
middle of the night to see a ghost and I
still haven't seen one and it's making
me crazy
we told there she used to play hard to
get a little bit you know I don't have
anything to do with ghosts whatever a
Pokemon or it goes haunted hotel here
you stay there and you also got haunted
there I'm sure I'm very jealous I stayed
in the room with the woman yeah the
whole story I purposely like we got the
room to stay in with my one of my
ex-boyfriends and he was again it was
again a skeptic so we went on the ghost
tour around San Diego and I swear to god
all the lights went out and we're like
oh my gosh and then we just found out
that there was a power outage why have a
friend who's staying at that hotel right
now I saw him at a party last night and
he was like oh yeah I felt weird and
then yeah the Coronado and then you
google and it's one particular room
buddy staying in my room and he said
there was scraping on the walls banging
on the walls and many biggest setup you
guys he's like yeah I'm gonna stay there
it's gonna be fun I'm like what are you
doing get out you're being the skeptic
now you're gonna call it in again for
the river done if I'm gonna get haunted
as soon as I get back to the hotel
something I liked about this movie when
it comes to you guys and it seems like
you have this natural connection as we
speak as well I know you didn't get much
of a chance to do rehearsals so how did
you or any chance not at all cast I
think about 36 hours before we ended up
in
with our clothes on trailer we're like
hi mom hi daughter and five minutes
later we were working connection then
between you guys yeah it was really
organic but yeah at that point it's like
alright we just got to act we've known
each other forever we love each other
but we also hate each other and you know
we also have kids and I got at home and
take mine to school and you have to have
a tooth the reason I met in the hallway
like two minutes before I first seen so
that was fun I met Alex like about life
helped me grow up a better man become a
better man together you know acting like
this so I'm sure you do take after take
of being terrified how hard is it to
like all right it's like the fifth tank
rolls around and you've already screamed
your brains out physically this one lost
their voice a couple of days right yeah
I blew out my tank about my voice low
for a while um but yeah it can be taxing
I mean certainly like round take seven
I'm like oh god I have a headache I've
been crying I've been sobbing me just
keep doing it and it's it's I mean I'm
so happy to have the job that I have and
I'm so grateful that Mike this isn't
that bad like this is pretty cool
but yeah I have to say I was most
impressed by Gabe because I felt like
his performance is sorry unwavering he
seems terrified like every frame of the
movie I was like that's real I don't
know how you don't scream most of the
time you know
scream Teresa and I had a little bit of
a screaming contest in the basement
screaming for our mom that's right it
was definitely baby God that's when I
pull out my voice box yeah are you guys
hard I'm assume that you're not a horror
fan yeah are you even allowed to watch
this movie you seen it twice sort of
half the screen the second time I saw
about four three three or four quarters
yeah
do you guys have a favorite horror movie
or something that you think that this I
think it's unlike most horror movies or
most ghost stories but is there anything
that you sort of think it's alike for me
Silence of the Lambs I know it's not
exactly horde I'm the weird guy that
like we said at the beginning it's it
can you take out the horror as a SPECT
it stands alone as a family film of
people going through real life struggles
know many other or films like that
poltergeist had the babadook the
babadook for sure
I'm impressed the babadook also I don't
know if you've seen it but there's their
sign of a similarity with what's going
on with your character - not revealing
anything good what I liked you though is
that especially I felt like you guys
were making smart decisions where's so
many times in horror movies I mean it's
part of the fun that you're like don't
go in the baby but you did go to the
basement with a logical idea which is
even though it's the darkest area in the
house and I'm probably gonna get locked
in there and killed by cars but still
it's a great deal yeah besides that
other than that one gaping error besides
that though that was one of my favorite
parts about the movie because in most
horror films don't see they're like hey
let's go ask that guy with the chainsaw
for directions
yeah we don't make silly decisions it's
not campy right you want these you want
these characters to survive because
because they don't make silly decisions
horror movie we're like The Killers
waiting in the basement and someone's
about to go down and their friends like
you know what don't go down there and
then the movie's over
yeah well you guys are here in San Diego
during comic-con I imagine you guys I
know Teresa you've been here before yeah
what is it like when you're doing your
jobs it's like just kind of a blur of
interviews and to get to get much of a
chance to meet people meet the fan Oh
Teresa know been meeting a lot of
pokiman Thank You me on and then she got
addicted I mean it's the whole thing at
lunchtime I got it I've already captured
five I feel like that's such an
accomplishment I was like since a
lunchtime that's amazing
I thought it was called squiggly
squiggly water well we have had a chance
to meet a bunch of people I mean
obviously we've been doing back to back
interviews yeah but there are so many
great fans who are excited about the
movie and then all the different
incredible characters dressed up and he
saw an interesting one today what I what
I thought was a nude man but he was
wearing a little flap he's a pokey man
that must be hey guys we're getting
close to the end but before we go we've
talked so much about this film and
you've legitimately gotten me excited
about seeing it and a little bit nervous
but if Gabe can do it I can do it we
have the trailer for lights out I'd love
to uh sorry guys right now
all right let's take a look at the
trailer for lights out
every time I turn off the lights there's
this woman waiting in the shadows I see
her - each one of us
is being haunted
huh hey Martin what's up did we wake you
and something really bad happened to her
everyone is afraid of the dark
that's what she feeds on
no we need to find more like you guys
are sleeping with the lights on tonight
after all
oh my goodness
and that's the thing it's like oh what's
scary that a monster not knowing what's
in the dark oh I know it gets closer I
just yeah I can't I can't
I'm just terrified frightening
frightening yeah so uh I think we're
getting close to the end here of of our
first screen junkies central episode man
so I want to thank you guys the audience
can you give yourselves a big round of
applause when I say screen junkies you
say central screen junkies screen
junkies yes you guys I want to thank you
I want to thank everybody watching on
the live screen on the live stream don't
forget you can subscribe to screen
junkies plus for half off right now it's
amazing thanks for watching tune in for
the rest of our festivities bye bye
thanks again to sponsor t-mobile with
double the LTE coverage get your screen
junkies fix and more places to watch our
previous show click to the left and to
view everything else from screen junkie
central click to the right